right now everybody is wondering what is
going to happen with the deal between
Sony and Disney about spider-man being
in the MCU how's it going everybody it's
Warren and it seems like this morning we
have a bit of news concerning the deal
now keep in mind at this point in time
it's just a rumor and until Sony or
Disney releases an official statement it
is not confirmed but if this deal
between Sony and Disney does end up
happening it is going to be great news
for spider-man fans and MCU fans so I'll
break it all down but first if you'd
like a chance to win an Xbox one or a
ps4 be sure to subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your favorite superhero or villain I'll
be picking a new winner at 500,000
subscribers so according to cosmic book
news.com Disney has offered Sony another
deal over keeping spider-man in the MCU
which will include a 7 picture deal new
Avengers films and an appearance at the
d23 Expo and according to cosmic book
news.com this is Disney's proposal a 6
picture deal with Tom Holland with an
option for a 7th three more spider-man
films after spider-man 3 which will be a
new trilogy the second trilogy will
focus on Peter Parker's college years
including plans for Peter to meet up and
team up with Firestar and Iceman of the
x-men the other three movies are two
Avengers films in which spider-man will
have a larger role and become friends
with Johnny Storm the Human Torch from
the Fantastic Four Marvel Studios
Willhelm in co-financed all spider-man
related movies for 30% of the full
profits Sony would distribute but Disney
will acquire exclusive digital and
online rights for Disney Plus and
affiliated TV networks Marvel Studios
Wilhelm & Co finance spider-verse
live-action spin-offs under the same
terms venom will relocate into the MCU
Sony will be given permission for TV
live-action programs based on
spider-verse properties and according to
this report Disney and Sony want this
done before the d23 Expo Marvel's panel
for the d23 Expo is tomorrow so they
don't have much time an additional
detail provided by the site is that Tom
Holland wants to stay in the MCU which
of course he does he was cast for the
MCU specifically so this is the current
report from cosmic book news.com that
Sony and Disney are renegotiating a deal
for spider-man to be in the MCU now
cosmic book news
komm says that this info comes from TiVo
from the Lords of the long box YouTube
channel that has an insider source who
has connections at Disney and I know
that a lot of you are really excited
about this report but remember nothing
is confirmed yet and this all seems a
little too good to be true
having spider-man meet up with the x-men
and the Fantastic Four is something that
could definitely and will probably
happen but does seem like wishful fan
thinking the same goes for venom
entering the MCU as well although their
word talks for a while that venom was
going to appear in spider-man 3 which of
course was originally going to be in the
MCU so this report could very well be
true but again it's not confirmed yet so
take it with a grain of salt again if I
hear anything about the sony disney deal
i'll be sure to do a video to make sure
everybody is updated so let me know what
you think about this deal this deal
sounds like it would make spider-man
fans and MCU fans very very happy so
leave a comment down below and also
don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 and so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof